- [Instructor] Hey,
quick question for you.
You ever look at a person's baby pictures
and wonder how people go from
being small to, well, big?
I mean, yes, I get it.
People grow up, but
here, I'm thinking more
on the level of the atoms and molecules
that make up the body
because A, I'm a scientist
and that's kind of what we do,
and then also B, because after all,
all the changes we see
on these larger scales
are just reflections of
very many changes occurring
on the molecular scale.
And so if you think about it that way,
then it's likely reasonable to assume
that because the adult's body is bigger,
it has more molecules
and/or larger molecules
than the baby's body.
And so this means that there
are some molecules in this baby
and those molecules are
interacting and combining
with some other source
of molecules in the world
in order to become this adult.
And generally speaking,
the source of those molecules
is going to be our diet,
AKA our food.
And to kind of understand this,
we can actually make a comparison here
between food and wood.
So what I mean by that
is that the molecules in food
interact with the molecules on our bodies
in two primary ways.
The first is as a source of
molecular building blocks,
or in other words,
molecules the body can use
to build new structures.
And the second is going to be
as a source of molecules for fuel,
much like a campfire or
firewood, like what we have here.
But in order to understand
how and why this can happen,
we need to briefly discuss
the molecular basis of food.
So what are the molecules in food?
Let me introduce you.
All right, 'cause generally speaking,
food is made up of these
three classes of molecules.
First up are fats,
then we've got sugars,
and finally some protein.
I'd imagine some of these
sound reasonably familiar.
These molecules are made basically
from just a few elements.
So this is color-coded and
the gray balls are carbon.
The white ones are hydrogen.
Those are the big ones.
So most of life's molecules
are made mostly of carbon and hydrogen.
But we've also got oxygen here in red
and nitrogen in blue,
those are the other two big ones.
And every now and then,
we'll also find small amounts
of some other elements,
like this sulfur here in yellow.
But the super interesting part here
is that these are actually
the same exact elements
that make up most of
the cells in your body.
So you may notice on this right-hand side
the same colors is what
we have on the left.
So this is where the whole
Molecular Lumber thing comes in.
Our cells can take food
and break it down into
small building blocks
and then use those building blocks
in order to build new
structures in our body.
So is how we grow.
This is how babies become adults.
Turns out, we actually are what we eat.
It's pretty amazing.
All right, but before we get too excited,
let's bring it in.
So let's switch gears for a second here
to talk about the other side of things
because I told you before
that food is like wood.
And we can use wood to
build new structures, sure.
But when we need to,
we can also burn wood to get energy.
So we can start a campfire.
And if we do, we know that
we're gonna get some energy
in the form of light,
we'll get some energy in the form of heat,
and maybe some other things like sound.
And food is actually the same way,
and so we can take those
same food molecules
that we broke down before
to get building blocks
and instead use them as fuel
to generate cellular energy.
And then we can use that cellular energy
to fuel all of the building
that we just talked about.
And likewise, if our cells
work together, which they do,
they can use this energy
to do things like running,
thinking, and all the other
things that we humans do.
All right.
Let's step back just one more time
because what we'll see is
that these two processes
that we've just described,
so food is lumber and food is fuel
actually explain so much of life.
So this is not just us.
Every living thing on
this planet is doing this.
So you feed your dog
to fuel his or her molecular
construction projects as well.
So right there and then,
we've already kind of answered
our question from before,
which, reminder, was:
how do people go from small to big?
So what's happening is that
this baby becomes an adult
by eating food, milk,
formula, gushy stuff,
I don't know, whatever babies eat.
And some of the molecules in that food
will be used as fuel to generate energy,
and then some of that energy
will be used to combine food molecules
with molecules in the baby
to build up a larger baby, AKA an adult.
All right, I hope that helps.
Let's wrap it here.
See you in the next one.